all right so this is sky which and
clearly the return of one of the biggest
questions ever asked will they use the
word goof again and they did they
usually I was wonderful yeah actually
when they said it both of them kind of
almost lost in a bit we're totally cool
we're a lab school we're like yeah we
were like so it's like you know it's not
laughing out loud but it's like you know
acknowledging there was something aboard
in that joke so so yeah I really like
this episode I thought this episode was
a lot of fun it was really creative it
it answers a bit more about like
Marceline and Bubblegum's uh I guess
past together apparently they do they
said they knew this sky witch before
right the yeah yeah they mentioned her
by name I think correct I don't think
they knew her I think they knew about
her okay because Marceline knew that Ash
sold hambo to her but also bubblegum
already knew when she said I found the
sky witch bubblegum already knew what
that was kind of about like she's been
chasing yeah but that's what I'm saying
like it doesn't mean that like they
actually knew knew her or anything like
might they have met her they at least
have knowledge of yeah Marshallese
probably learned about uh who she was
and it's been looking for for a long
time other ash sold
hambo I was saying I was saying I was
getting a little bit more like it they
had a past history but you're right if
they finally if she found out like from
Ash who he sold like the doll to you
know very teddy bear whatever you know
then she'll probably know about it or
they she would know the name and be like
hey I gotta find this person
yeah um so okay so pretty much um
Marceline comes in tells bubblegum that
she needs her to help her out on this
quest it's really just to get her teddy
bear back and but at this huge
sentimental value so they go into the
sky which is lair forest
what was that again it was cool I just
okhane it don't man there you go
um and it's just them going around
through all these cool creative things
and fighting all these cool obstacles
they insert their own different ways and
eventually they come to they they come
to the sky which and the sky which
trades trades the doll for Bubblegum's
shirt the shirt that we did see before
right wasn't that a thing from that 1f
is Marceline gave it to her yeah so
training apparently has some sort of
incredible power sentimental power
something that's gonna make this guy was
really really powerful and she spends
the remainder of the episode zapping her
rabbit or Grovyle woke I grabbed her Oh
rabbit
whatever it was called it was great they
are all four or five days ahead and I
love the creativity in this one I love
the I love kind of the sentimental stuff
going out with her looking for the teddy
bear I love the I love the way these to
work off each other like a like a
bubblegum can very easily
relax herself and float through the
where the the passive force feel
whenever it was and Marceline has more
of a problem you know but when it comes
to kicking a sea Marceline fight the
crab it or whatever
oh that fight was wonderful by the way
because it was both really bad acid
really clumsy like I love I love what
she thinks she sees the doll turns out
the crab it and she's like you know I'll
kill you and he just slammed the door on
her and then she just open it back up
it's like well of course that's not
gonna stop her it's just like this mild
and okey yeah and the whole thing is
like the whole fight is nothing but like
really bad ass moves mixed with mild
annoyance it's yeah I love I love the
crap it's he wanted to be a dancer that
was really funny oh and yeah driving
what else I just loved all the different
rooms they went into I loved I loved the
deductive reasoning that bubblegum used
I love nope nope I love that yeah and
yeah you know I say the only thing I
think I brought it up before that really
makes me quite
things is you know cuz in the beginning
it was always like you know oh no
bubblegum we have to say bubblegum and
now it's like not only have what you see
and she has this really sort of whether
good or bad she definitely has a dark
side I mean just in this opening like
you know makeup
fists with your mind and punch it in the
face and say he was Janet I mean it's
like she's got this really a hardcore
side to her but yeah I'm really
wondering you know if they're a you know
and she's not is she so scientific now
that everything is no nonsense I mean
she's the only Marceline come on get a
clue come on where I'm thinking to
myself this is the stuff she would shout
at first season her I could see first
season her like seeing the teddy bear
like oh let's go look I mean to me it
seems like an almost totally different
character which I don't think is bad I
think she's much more interesting this
way um but it does make me kind of
wonder if there was I mean I've even
seen them use it intentionally yet I
mean like where she starts off you know
just kind of
she's the happy you know very
stereotypical princess just happy with
everything and stuff and now it's like
if everything's sort of like this heavy
burden might feels like this burden she
has to take and she's not happy with it
but just has to be done it's she's so
much more interesting now oh and yeah
sometimes it really can't dive over into
that dark so I like blow she's saying
with the raggedy princess is like just
what I'm like alright I like Princess
Bubblegum sweet this is an episode I
like this one and then she comes out
with that are like oh I bet you Linda
really dig it now I actually really dig
those and I don't know if it's because
where we started with her character or
if it's just funny on itself but I
really like how you know she's generally
positive and the speaks and scientific
you scientifically that was just do
something really messed up and dark you
know like whatever just having the
little play things I like cut off the
legs or somebody's I've been flinching I
mean it's like little things like that
are not really making me laugh and I
just
like that there is a little bit more of
a character to her now um but yeah we
got another beginning of a villain it
looks like with the sky which uh the
voice was great not really funny you
know it sounds like a couple voices
going on there but they all like great
delivery um you know hearing the
sinister voice say you know you cannot
disprove my profile practice I mean it's
great so I just loved I thought was
really really fun this is my hambo but
her name is mean you know I really liked
this one and the opening with again like
with people's just saying that it's make
I will just lost it I love that I want
to use that it's I I don't know why but
it corrects me the hell up because I'm
picturing it yeah you know like come
true like how do you how do you do that
find a way and it's interesting first of
all that shirt she already had it back
in the episode when we were the door
episode the door guy she already had it
like cuz I remember even Marcy was like
oh you still have that I didn't know
like so it the witch was using it
I guess the witch takes her powers from
sentimental things so it wasn't that the
shirt was powerful but that because it
had so many memories and I guess it was
their way of telling us that you know
this shirt meant like a bajillion things
to Wells and then if you think about it
- she gives up one of her most important
possessions to get it back for Marcy
well what's interesting about that is
that that would sort of mean that can we
don't know really yet the history of
this year we just know was Marceline and
that was Bubblegum's
and if that's more powerful than the
doll and you see how much Marceline
hasn't
no it's like what is the story yeah when
people's opens her closet to you see
like a tiny little picture yeah also
wondering that too so yeah what is going
on I'm thinking more and more with the
the long where we see the past with you
know ice game Marceline and you see that
pink gunk that you were saying was
probably bubblegum not so bad and now
I'm really not oh it's not that good you
want me to tell you what if we're not
gonna find out okay from the video game
which I had not played but I hear people
consistently talking about as far as I
can tell and it could be wrong but it
sounds like that's pb's parents or the
beginning of her parents okay that's
what it sounds like well at least well
even even with that um it shows that
there's just some sort of connection
going back really far back and you know
and maybe the peoples at some point sir
I don't know if she could pick up where
Ice King what talk if she ages normally
I think the way way no no no it was like
because I went but so they say she's
like 18 or something right hundreds of
years old remember the suitor and the
guy's been waiting there in those people
he took his father's place in line oh my
god a bus so where she's suddenly late
team well but that's because remember
she died and then they but they say
they're like couple he said no it takes
away five years so she was 18 right I
don't know what do you mean you know no
you're like that's right here um I liked
the crabbit but the funny thing is is
when I every time you hear crab it and I
know it's not the same I think of Tenchi
Muyo attention oil with Dario Loki he's
a cabbage he's a Catholic
he's a yeah part cat and part rabbit Wow
oh that's it is that what that is this
is a pig rabbit excuse me pig rabbit and
her name is menu so every time I heard
that in this that's what I know is
pictures a little ryo-ohki
but um I
like the beginning where she wakes up
with the cat does to me at four o'clock
in the morning 30
I swear to god he's no way come they try
to choke you it's like no no it's I
think that that's a sign that cats are
psychopaths because their sign of love
is trying to strangle yo never strangles
me he only use a different thing he
drops on my face from the windowsill up
top woke up to that one morning but yeah
sorry you were saying
no I like that I loved excuse me when a
hambo pops up in the forest and Marcy
starts flipping out like oh my god and
people's is like what the hell is wrong
with you how are you she even say yeah
yeah when did he start to talk you know
and all that stuff I love that though
that the emotion for hambo just kind of
took over and it was that whole thing I
need hambo back I don't care
I yeah obviously hambo doesn't talk
himbo doesn't move but it didn't matter
at that point in time because it's one
of the most important things to her also
you guys forget failed to mention what
brie notice yes yes via the picture in
the Attic yes of the whatever the slug
girl whatever now I'd like to also
mention one other thing it was only very
briefly because there's the picture of
her but then there's also another shot
of the painting where it's an angry shot
really yes yeah no I didn't catch that
that's interesting the the answer to
that will kind of be solved in the vault
okay it's a little bit further down the
road okay
I'm intrigued but there is a reason why
it went from I think from one shot of
the picture to one where it's also angry
I I do wonder sometimes if like they
just caught themselves like animation
err I'll answer in this episode of
herself
nothing up it's been building that's it
okay it's very interesting
um I I'm sorry if I was PB or Marceline
I'd be like this was stolen from me your
whole contract and thing is null and
void because it was not his to begin
with give me it back I maybe I don't
know it's I'm just saying I'd punch her
in the face and no no no but they were
in a relationship right
still Marceline yeah but that's what
broke it off yeah is he sold and oh no
no but they were still in a relationship
yeah I know so you know when they kind
of know you're dating does that mean
that leave me if me if me and you were
dating I've already done it with half
your stuff including murder party now I
want to get for myself look at your cat
no it's your cat now he's airing out his
junk yeah well the people can't see that
so yeah we'll give you an idea like that
there you go good we all know it's
Naruto show I mean we we sorry you drew
attention to it this time not me I just
had to show the people cuz you know busy
doing is a porn star so oh yeah and my
wife apparently informs me that I've put
like 70s porn star look at what's ours
like you have porn hair like 70s porn
don't worry we're gonna get it cut very
very soon oh yeah that's the siren call
yeah oh yeah I've seen this I'll go back
to the cab
if you forget this is going on make me
forgive this is going on